j'ai appelé monsieur Macron pour le
féliciter de son élection et parce que
j'ai à cœur l'intérêt supérieur du pays
je lui ai souhaiter de réussir face aux
immenses défis auxquels la France est
confrontée je veux remercier les 11
millions de Français qui m'ont accordé
leur voix et leur confiance ainsi que
les militants qui m'ont soutenu et
accompagné tout au long de cette
campagne je remercier également Nicolas
dupontignan et son mouvement debout la
France ainsi que les personnalités qui
m'ont soutenu pour leur choix courageux
et
fondateur par ce résultat historique et
massif les Français ont désigné
l'alliance patriote et républicaine
comme la première force d'opposition au
projet du nouveau président les
formations politiqu qui ont pris la
responsabilité de faire élir monsieur
Macron se sont discrédité elles-mêm et
ont perdu toute légitimité à représenter
une force d'alternance ou même
d'opposition
crédible le premier tour a entiné une
décomposition majeure de la vie
politique française par l'élimination
des partis anciens ce second tour
organise une recomposition politique de
grande ampleur autour du clivage entre
les patriotes et les mondialistes c'est
ce grand choix qui par circonscription
sera soumis aux Français lors des
législatives je serai à la tête de ce
combat afin de rassembler plus largement
encore tous ceux qui veulent chois la
France défendre son indépendance sa
liberté sa prospérité sa sécurité son
identité et son modèle social tant nous
sommes inquiets des perspectives
qu'offre ce nouveau
quinquena le Front National qui s'est
engagé dans une stratégie d'alliance
doit lui aussi profondément se
renouveler afin d'être à la hauteur de
cette opportunité historique et des
attentes des Français exprimé lors de ce
second tour je proposerai donc d'engager
une transformation profonde de notre
mouvement afin de constituer une
nouvelle force politique que de nombreux
Français appellent de leur vœux et qui
est plus que jamais nécessaire au
redressement du pays j'appelle tous les
patriotes à nous rejoindre afin de
participer au combat politique décisif
qui commence dès ce soir plus que jamais
dans les mois qui viennent la France
aura besoin de VOUS vive la République
vive la
France
[Applaudissements]
bra voilà pour cette déclaration de
Marine Le Pen